dunkelste ort das ist leider eine gute
überleitung höchster heute morgen 7 uhr
torben hartmann 35 jahre als startet
seinen 220 ps bagger dann lässt er die
schaufel in dach wände und fenster eines
hauses krachen 200 stunden später ist
nur noch ein großer schutthaufen zu
sehen dass horror haus von rockstar
existiert nicht mehr
dieses haus war schauplatz von
gräueltaten die man sich kaum vorstellen
mag ein ort des schreckens das horror
haus in höxter jahrelang waren auf dem
grundstück mehrere frauen von wilfried
weh und seiner ex frau und komplizin
angelika missbraucht und gequält worden
zwei opfer starben an ihren schweren
verletzungen
besonders widerlich eine leiche wurde
zuerst tiefgefroren dann zersägt und
später verbrannt eine frau starb im
krankenhaus
jetzt wird das haus endlich abgerissen
um halb sechs die baustelle eingerichtet
mit containern und wie maschinen das war
schon ein komisches gefühl wenn man da
einen herumläuft und
ganz komisch ist wenn man dann offen so
sieht man wo die vorderen verbrannt
worden sein soll und wo wir die
badewanne gefunden hat wo die hier
geschaffen haben der forschung komisch
bis februar war das horror haus noch im
besitz des landes nordrhein westfalen
dann wurde es der stadt höxter
übertragen um den schandfleck des ortes
abreißen lassen zu können
das horror haus sollte nicht weiter zum
ziel von schaulustigen und grusel
touristen gemacht werden nach dem abriss
soll mutter boden aufgeschüttet werden
und eine grünfläche entstehen damit
möglichst wenig an die bestie von
höchster erinnert komplizin angelika
wurde 2018 übrigens zu 13 jahren haft
verknackt die best hier von höchster
wilfried w nur zu 11 nach einem
gutachten galt er wegen seiner
intellektuellen minderbegabung als
vermindert schuldfähig
das wird aber jetzt angezweifelt
bedeutet da könnten noch einige jahre
mehr drauf kommen hoffen wir es